in our morning rounds the new concerns
about previously rare types of tick
borne diseases that are being seen more
frequently in this country the black
legged tick not only spreads look at
that guy Lyme disease it can also
transmit a serious virus that may have
killed one man and made another sick in
New Jersey and in Kentucky a two year
old boy reportedly is recovering from
another tick borne disease Rocky
Mountain spotted fever dr. David agus is
in Los Angeles and joins us with
everything you need to know about ticks
today so David let's start with this how
widespread is it and how serious it is
how serious is it if you happen to get
bitten by a tick so they are ugly let's
get that out of the way so it is growing
and you know with 60,000 cases about a
year ago of tick borne diseases and
that's how many were actually reported
the real number is probably over 300,000
you know ticks are parasites they jump
onto a mouse a rat or a squirrel and
they're viruses and bacteria that live
inside of them they draw their blood and
then in their life cycle they'll bite us
and they can transmit these diseases to
us why are we seeing more cases now
David well the weather's changing
climate is changing and there are more
mice there more food for the ticks as
well as the ticks and so as
reforestation happens as climate change
happens different areas of the countries
are getting more of these what's the
best way to remove a tick if you find it
and if you then have a desire to torture
that tick does that make you a bad
person is it I am NOT here to give
ethical commentary your behavior so take
you straight to users pull straight out
and put the tick into alcohol the
quicker you remove it the better because
it takes time before it can injects its
saliva in you in the saliva what's is
what contains the bacteria and the virus
so wear your pants tucked into your
socks have someone check you which can
be kind of fun after a hike and look all
over you make sure the no ticks or take
a shower as quick as possible is there
anything you can do David Tet to
actually avoid tick bites yes
stay with gale indoors in the middle of
a trail David no bears sometimes I like
to go on a hike
I believe you so are not I think are the
disease's treatable smarty Pasha are
they the benefit of being outside yeah
prompts the risk of getting one of these
diseases bacterial diseases like Lyme
disease are treatable but what we saw in
northern New Jersey is two cases of
Powis and virus which is not treatable
and it's got a ten percent mortality
rate and 50% of people who get this
virus have permanent Learner illogic
injury so to have someone search you for
ticks and pull them off right afterwards
if you have it and avoid it where DEET
David agus thank you very much